una propuesta de la reforma fiscal que
propuso el entonces presidente iván
duque desencadenó las protestas más
multitudinarias de los últimos años en
el país y ahora petro también propone un
proyecto de reforma por un monto similar
25 billones de pesos e incluso más
ambiciosa cuéntenos en qué se diferencia
este proyecto del que hizo duque
bueno el monto de recaudo es mayor
digámoslo así que que la que hizo lo que
duque quería recaudar alrededor de 20
millones
pero quienes van a pagar los impuestos
es una cosa completamente diferente
entonces la progresividad de esta
reforma que está proponiendo
el gobierno entrante es muy distinta a
la de la que propuso en su momento el
ministro carrasquilla por varias razones
primero
comenzábamos desde más o menos desde los
5 millones en 5 millones de pesos
hogares con 5 millones de producción a
comenzar a declarar y a pagar renta en
esa época cierto y más o menos desde los
3 millones 800 se van a comenzar a
declarar yo creo honestamente que todo
el mundo debería declarar renta cierto
pero la renta si la deberían pagar
hogares con ingresos un poco más alto
esta reforma comienza en los 10 millones
de pesos lo cual a mí tampoco me parece
del todo bueno
deberíamos comenzar un poco antes
deberíamos comenzar más o menos a los 78
millones de pesos a subir los montos de
pago para que esto sea un todos ponen
en
uno de los puntos de la reforma
tributaria de petro es aplicar un
impuesto al carbono explíquenos en qué
consistiría y qué tan factible es que el
congreso lo apruebe teniendo en cuenta
el lobby de las grandes empresas
ahí hay un hay una creatividad el
ministro digamos en él en esta reforma
tributaria
por supuesto que las grandes empresas
tienen lobby pero se está vendiendo como
un impuesto a las exportaciones después
de determinado monto y eso de obviamente
de los combustibles fósiles se
contaminan y eso me parecería
digamos inconveniente porque nosotros
necesitamos toda la inversión que para
venir para el sector petrolero por un
lado y por otro lado necesitamos también
los ingresos que están viniendo de la
venta de petróleo que internacionalmente
nos ha favorecido con un buen precio
entonces hay una gran interrogante es
una de las de las cosas polémicas que se
están proponiendo
y vamos a ver si lo logran acordémonos
que tienen mayoría en el congreso y qué
tan factible es que el congreso apruebe
esta reforma
yo creo que es muy factible yo creo que
es una reforma fácil de vender desde el
punto de vista político yo creo que
faltó a pesar de que se hizo porque supe
que se hizo para la socialización un
poco con él
o la sociedad civil con con los gremios
sé que se hicieron varias reuniones con
los grandes donde se les mostraba el
sentido de la reforma quitar los los
los beneficios tributarios a esas
empresas que tenían algunos beneficios
injustificados
básicamente unir todos los
las fuentes de
ingreso para cobrar un solo impuesto al
ingreso total de la persona y todas esas
cosas van en la dirección correcta
entonces yo creo que es una reforma
relativamente fácil de vender que afecta
a los más ricos